Німецьке пиво як рушій технічного прогресу
Пивна в якій вирішувалися долі країн
Всередині найстарішої броварні світу
Крафтові броварі - порушники закону
Друзі, усім привіт! Мюнхен багато хто вважає пивною столицею Німеччини.
Баварська якість і традиції притягують поціновувачів пінного хмільного напою з усього світу.
Зокрема на культовий Октоберфест.
Пиво не лише в Баварії, а й в усій Німеччині відіграє важливу роль у культурі, економіці та побуті німців.
Пропоную почати дослідження впливу пива на німецьке суспільство з всесвітньовідомої пивної Гофбройхаус.
У 1589 році за наказом герцога Баварії Вільгельма V у його міському замку Альтер Гоф, відкрили броварню у приміщеннях курника та лазні.
Коли у 1806 році Баваріястала королівством, відповідно і Hofbräuhaus став королівським.
Гасло над входом – "Спрага гірша за сум за рідною домівкою".
Для веселішого подолання спраги - баварські мелодії наживо.
Ті, хто вже подолав спрагу - співають і танцюють на столах.
Це тут дозволено, як і вирізання пам'ятних написів на дубових дошках столів.
Баварці йдуть на пиво, як на свято - у традиційних костюмах.
Все своє, автентичне - навіть спосіб цокатися келихами.
Це батько і син. Після знайомства запитую у них, так в чому ж секрет світового успіху німецького пива.
Основою цього є закон про чистоту пива, який походить із середньовіччя і
чітко регулює інгредієнти, з яких варять напій, аби уникнути небажаних домішок.
Також у нас багато броварень, і всі вони обирають різні смакові напрямки.
Будівлю, у якій до сьогодні існує пивна Гофбройгаус, спорудили у 1607 році.
В усіх її залах і внутрішньому дворі можуть розміститися одночасно до 4 тисяч поціновувачів хмільного напою.
Привілей постійних відвідувачів - іменні пивні кухлі, що зберігаються в спеціальних шафах під замками.
Споживання пива почало розвиватися у Баварії у середньовіччі.
Тоді пиво варили ченці у монастирях, для вжитку в період постів.
З 19-го століття пиво стає одним з найважливіших напоїв, раніше у середньовіччі більше пили вина.
А яка ваша улюблена марка?
Важко сказати. Будь-яке пиво у Баварії смакує.
Найкраще смакує у "масі" - це стандартний баварський літровий кухоль.
Свого часу хильнути пінного сюди навідувався композитор Вольфґанґ Амадей Моцарт,
пізніше на початку 20 століття за цими столами випивав Ленін,
а згодом і партія Гітлера проводила тут свої щорічні збори.
Голова йде обертом, коли замислюєшся, що ці стіни просто дихають історією.
Ну що ж, друзі, сьогодні мені пощастило гуляти по Мюнхену з паном Ґісом - він історик-культуролог.
Любі глядачі з України, я радий вам сьогодні показати кілька місць у Мюнхені, які пов'язані з історією пива.
Після пива у Мюнхені є чим зайнятися і на що подивитися.
Поки я не підійшов, з-за спин було важко навіть уявити, за чим спостерігають ці збентежені глядачі.
За серфінгістами у центрі міста!
На світлофорі трапились ось такі кумедні гонщики на мінікарах.
Навколо - грандіозні палаци, парки та церкви, що нагадують про величне королівське минуле Баварії.
Однак Гаральд Ґіс веде мене подалі від туристичного центру, аби показати, який слід пивна історія лишила й у віддалених житлових районах.
За мною ви бачите будівлю, де була броварня Юніон.
Підприємець Герман Шюляйн володів нею і пізніше у 20-х роках 20-го століття придбав ще й броварню Льовенброй.
Це була одна з найбільших пивних імперій тогочасного Мюнхена.
Єврейська родина Шюляйн з приходом до влади націонал-соціалістів була змушена згорнути свій бізнес,
і нащадок пивної імперії, син Шюляйна, емігрував до США.
Тепер у будинку броварні – квартири, і меморіальна табличка нагадує мешканцям про його непросту історію.
Ми на площі Шюляйна, названої на честь Йозефа Шюляйна.
Цей фонтан - присвята броварям того часу. Хлопчик тримає лопату, якою розмішували солод.
Далі з Гаральдом Ґісом йдемо в один із понад півсотні мюнхенських Бірґартенів.
Дослівно - пивний сад. Традиція пити пиво саме під каштанами народилася двісті років тому.
Для кращої теплоізоляції над пивними підвалами висаджували каштани, які утворювали густу тінь.
Спраглі покупці дегустували пиво не відходячи від погрібів.
Тоді пиво зберігали в діжках у льодових погребах.
Викопували льох і взимку зносили у нього кригу, щоб вона влітку охолоджувала пиво.
У таких пивних просто неба можна було придбати лише пиво, закуску треба було приносити із собою.
У своєму указі баварський король Максиміліан Перший заборонив броварям продавати їжу у Бірґартенах,
аби вони не відбирали хліб у трактирників. Сьогодні в пивних садах можна замовити найрізноманітніші закуски.
Бірґартени в теплу пору року стають центрами соціалізації, де розмови за пивом не вщухають до пізнього вечора.
У своїх Бірґартенах німці можуть спробувати близько 5 тисяч сортів пива, які виробляють щонайменше півтори тисячі броварень.
На цьому місці варять пиво з 1040 року. Щоб відчути силу традицій, пропоную завітати до найстарішої броварні світу.
Цікаво, що поруч з броварнею розташовані корпуси технічного університету Мюнхена,
в котрих базується дослідний центр пивної промисловості та факультет броварства, який вважається одним з найкращих у світі.
Зранку я застав момент завантаження солоду, який привезли з фермерського господарства за 20 кілометрів від броварні.
Навколо пива тут сформувалося і академічно-дослідницьке середовище, і економіка регіону.
Солод засипають сюди і далі він транспортується в ось вежу.
Там він зберігається у спеціальних ємностях і з них подається у цех пивоваріння.
Піднімаємось у цех варіння, a тут усім керує комп'ютер - від підтримання температури у котлах до подачі хмелю.
Одна людина на зміні стежить за показниками на моніторі.
І знову маємо докази впливу пива на німецьке сільське господарство.
Наш хміль походить з баварського регіону Галлертау - найбільшого виробника хмілю у світі.
Це приблизно 5 кілометрів від броварні на північ. У нас там є фермери, які спеціально на замовлення вирощують для нас цей сорт.
У той час, як Матіас показував мені цистерни, де відбувається процес бродіння,
я намагався йому закинути, що, мовляв, закон про чистоту пива від 1516 року вже застарів іброварні
використовують його лише для просування свого продукту в світі. Маркетолог мені різко заперечив.
Жоден припис щодо чистоти продуктів у світі не гарантує такийабсолютно зрозумілий і прозорий спосіб
приготування продукту і чистоту сировини, як баварський закон чистоти пива.
Він дозволяє використовувати лише воду, солод, хміль та дріжджі. І це все!
Не лише в німецькому автопромі, а вже й у броварнях працюють ось такі роботи.
Пиво Вайенштефан постачається до 50-ти країн світу, зокрема й до України.
Броварня експорт-орієнтована і цю марку легше знайти у Києві, аніж у Мюнхені.
З цеху розливу три чверті продукції відправляються за кордон.
Нарешті найприємніша частина зйомки - Матіас запрошує на дегустацію.
В процесі відповіді на моє запитання - "А коли ж броварі відмовилися від криги в погребах?" -
з'ясувалося, що винайшли холодильник саме німецькі інженери:
Мабуть, найбільший вплив, який мала баварська пивна культура на розвиток техніки у суспільстві,
це винахід Карлом фон Лінде холодильної установки.
Карл фон Лінде був професором Мюнхенського технічного університету.
Відкриття першого такого холодильника відбулося у 1871 році.
Згодом установки, які генерували холод завдяки роботі парової машини, пропрацювали на броварні 100 років.
І ще одне - найстаріша броварня у світі має дуже рідкісний для ФРН тип власності -
вона належить федеральній землі Баварія, а керується баварським міністерством науки.
Після відвідин зразкової традиційної броварні хочеться подивитися, як працюють ті, хто порушує закон чистоти пива.
А зараз переносимося до землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія, у селище Нідербахем.
Давайте завітаємо до приватної крафтової броварні, яка виготовляє лише тисячу літрів пива на місяць.
Мене зустрічає власник підприємства Антоніо Санфеліу, який має колумбійське коріння.
Антоніо - єдиний працівник своєї броварні. Він самоук і переконує, що варити крафтове пиво - це дуже легко.
Бровар-аматор запатентував власну марку - Драхенфельзер Брауцойген, яка на локальному рівні користується великим попитом.
Моя думка, що раніше споживання пива було пасивним, люди зустрічалися в пивних та бірґартенах, пили пиво та спілкувалися.
Зараз спостерігається дедалі більше активного споживання пива.
Люди хочуть брати участь у варінні пива, цікавляться, як досягти різноманітності у смаках напою.
Завдякитаким як Антоніо у Німеччині за останні 30 років на третину зменшилося споживання
класичного німецького пива, звареного відповідно до  закону 1516 року.
Бровар експериментує з новими рецептами на своїй 30-літровій установці для пивоваріння,
аби потімвдалі рецепти повторити на 300-літровій.
Відсутність стабільного смаку у кожній новій звареній партії пива Антоніо вважає своєю перевагою.
Як ви бачите, об'єм інгредієнтів я ще можу приблизно бачити, але розрахувати все до літра вручну неможливо.
Тобто, завжди є мінімальні відхилення від рецепту. І сукупність таких чинників спричиняє те, що в підсумку пиво отримує трохи інший характер.
Наразі бровар має 4 основних власних унікальних сорти крафтового пива.
Зупинімось докладніше на сорті, звареному з додаванням яблук - це свідоме порушення середньовічного закону про чистоту напою.
Це пиво Мекем. Так називається, бо неподалік є місто Мекенгайм, відоме своїми чудовими яблуками.
Смак достатньо свіжий. Є присмак ферментованого яблука, легка фруктова нота, однак вона не така сильна і нема відчуття, наче п'єш яблучний сік.
Тут є характер брюту - сухий смак, немає багато цукру і солодкого присмаку, дуже добре збалансований.
Антоніо пішов у підвал вручну закорковувати пляшки і ліпити етикетки на яблучне пиво,
бо 5 ящиків його творіння вже замовили для регіонального фермерського ярмарку.
Друзі, це була заключна, 35 серія відеоблогу "Відкривай Німеччину з Михайлом Малим".
Майже чотири роки ми були з вами разом. Дякую вам за ваші коментарі, пропозиції тем, лайки, шери та підписки.
Бажаю вам міцного здоров'я і натхнення на нові звершення! Будьмо!